all right the script has been written
and rewritten and a brave executive has
said go
pre-production begins as soon as
possible before the brave executive
changes his mind teams of people start
filling officers planning scouting and
creating now if it shows up on screen is
for the someone months before an actor
steps on a set imagined it and made it
happen we honor these talented artists
tonight because they do not merely
design sets or costumes or make up their
design movies ladies and gentlemen
please welcome Sarah Jessica Parker and
Daniel Craig
the film now moves from the page to the
stage setting that stage is the
production designer sometimes he does it
on a soundstage and sometimes on a world
stage moving across continents and
cultures as well as decades it's a
daunting job this castle an old member
of a royal family looks much better
after the production designer has given
her a full facelift sometimes the
challenge is bizarre we all know what
Gotham City looks like or do we that it
always looked like Chicago seen through
a glass darkly some movies require
absolute authenticity demanding the
faithful depiction of Los Angeles in the
20s where people got dressed up to go to
work at the phone company well another
calls for meticulous a meticulous
recreation of American suburbia 30 years
later which looked like anything but the
prison it was the nominees for art
direction are the Curious Case of
Benjamin Button art direction by Donald
Graham Burt and set decoration by Victor
J's also the Duchess art direction by
Michael Carlin and set decoration by
Rebecca alloy the dark knight art
direction by nathan crowley and set
decoration by peter Lando changeling art
direction by James Jamie raqami and set
decoration by Gary fetes revolutionary
road art direction by Kristi Xia and set
decoration by Debra chute and the Oscar
goes to
The Curious Case of Benjamin Button
design it's all moaning grandpa
Wow we'd like to thank the Academy for
this wonderful honor we first and
foremost want to thank our crews that we
had in our art departments and those
crews were in New Orleans in Montreal in
Saint Thomas
and here in Los Angeles we want to thank
our producers Kathleen Kennedy Frank
Marshall and my dear friend of many
years Seon Chafin and I said at another
award ceremony that our producers were
great because they did what every
producer should ever do and that is
leave us alone I want to recognize one
person who has been very special to me
over this last few years and somebody
that I just think is a brilliant
director and even more so a wonderful
human being and that's my friend David
Fincher
and I want to recognize him because I
think he did so much to make this movie
so special and this movie means so much
to me and I want him to know that I
think that's that's it I want to thank
my lovely wife for everything she's done
for me thank you everybody and thank you
Academy and thank you mom and dad I love
you